من دنياتك تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره
حسان مسعود مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك كارمن
واخر المعلومات التي توفرت بشان هذا
الهجوم واسع النطاق التي تقول السلطات
الروسيه ان الجيش الاوكراني نفذه في خمس
مقاطعات امس
نعم ال سي في تطورات هذا الهجوم تطورات
عند عدد من الجبهات لعل ابرزها مارينكا
التي اقتربنا منها كثيرا قبل قليل وصلنا
الى اربع كيلومترات من هذه الجبهه وشاهدنا
بام العين القصف المتبادل بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه والتعزيزات العسكريه
التي تدفع بها روسيا باتجاه هذه الجبهه
التي تصفها وزاره الدفاع بالتكتيكيه اشاره
الى ان القوات الروسيه تقاتل بمؤازره قوات
احمد الشيشانيه على هذه الجبهه جبهه
مارينكا ولكن اليوم التفسيرات بالنسبه
للمحللين العسكريين الروس فيما جرى يوم
امس هو فشل في هذه الجبهه اضطر القوات
الاوكرانيه الى التراجع باتجاه جبهه كانت
توصف سابقا بالمستقر على مدى الاشهر
السابقه هي جبهه وهي ايضا تقع جنوبيه هذه
الج تم تسجيل عدد من الاقتحامات والهجومات
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في تلك الجبهه
قبل قليل ايضا وردت معطيات بان هناك عدد
من الهجمات نفذتها القوات الاوكرانيه ولكن
الروس من جهات يؤكدون احباط كل هذه
الهجمات هذه الهجمات نذكر انها طالت عددا
من المناطق في المقاطعات الجنوبيه في
اوكرانيا على راسها التي سجل فيها اكثر من
ثمان ساعات من الاشتباك بين القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه وفقه ما نقلت
السلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا في تلك
المقاطعه ايضا تم الحديث عن محاوله
لاجتياز زورقين وعدد من الاليات
الاوكرانيه نهر دنيبر ولكن ايضا بدورها
القوات الروسيه احبطت هذا المسعى في خرسون
ايضا استهدافات متكرره واليوم يجري تداول
بعض المعطيات على المواقع العسكريه
الروسيه
حول جبهات ممكن ان تفتح في المرحله
المقبله في شمال مقاطعه دونيتس مرتبطه
في الايام الماضيه كان هناك استهدافات
متكرره
المنطقه الواقعه تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه وهذا الامر يدلل بان ما تريده
روسيا في هذه المرحله اطباق الخناق او خلق
فكيكماشه واطباق الخناق على القوات
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه اليوم على الرغم من
هذه الهجومات في عدد من المقاطعات ولكن
وفق المعطيات الميدانيه يبدو ان العنوان
الحالي لهذه المعارك الاساس بالنسبه
للطرفين هي جبهه دونيات بالاحرى على مختلف
في جبهتها